[APPLAUSE]
HERALDO MUNOZ: Thank you
very much and pleased
to be back at Google
to talk about this book
that I wrote as a consequence
of having presided
the Commission of Inquiry
of the United Nations
into the Assassination
of Benazir Bhutto.
I was, at the time that I
was designated president
of this Commission
of Inquiry-- this
was in early 2009--
I was ambassador
of my country of Chile
to the United Nations.
And I got a phone call
while I was vacationing
in the south of Chile,
in the Patagonia,
from the Chief of Staff of the
Secretary General, Ban Ki Moon,
asking me whether I would
preside this commission that
was going to be
instituted to investigate
the assassination
of Benazir Bhutto.
Benazir Bhutto had
been assassinated
at a park in the
city of Rawalpindi,
right outside Islamabad, the
capital, in December of 2007.
I was very surprised
about this call
because I was a
sitting ambassador.
And, generally, individuals that
preside commissions of inquiry
are former prime ministers,
former foreign ministers,
or even former ambassadors.
But I was an
ambassador in office.
So I called my president,
President Michelle Bachelet,
thinking that she might say,
look this is a bit delicate.
Better say, no.
And, to my surprise, she said,
no, this is an honor for Chile
because Chile is
seen as trustworthy.
And it's a personal recognition
of your role at the UN,
so accept.
So I had no choice but to relay
that, yes, I would accept.
I had asked for 24 hours.
And I was told that
my mission would
be one of establishing the
facts and circumstances
of the assassination.
My commission would
not be a tribunal
that would establish whether
someone was guilty or not
in the assassination.
Which made it very complicated
because I thought--
I began to think that it would
be a lose-lose situation.
Because I could not
subpoena anyone,
anybody that would
be interrogated
would be voluntary.
And, in the end, I would not be
able to assign responsibility
for the assassination.
I would only be able to refer to
the facts and the circumstances
of the assassination.
And on the other hand, I thought
the Pakistani public and world
public opinion might expect
a lot from this commission.
They might expect that we would
come out with a smoking gun
and identifying who did it.
But nevertheless, I thought
I had to take it up.
I never knew exactly
why I was chosen.
Perhaps because I had
presided the al-Qaeda
and Taliban sanctions committee
while my country was member
of the Security Council
of the UN in 2003, 2004.
So I took it up
and then, later on,
the Secretary General
assigned two commissioners
to work with me.
A former Attorney
General of Indonesia
and a former deputy
police chief of Ireland.
Aside from a sizable
staff that helped us.
This was perhaps the
most challenging endeavor
I've been involved in.
I've been in politics
for quite a while.
I was in the resistance to
the dictatorship in my country
as a young man.
I spent time underground.
Then later on, I was a
member of the NO Committee
that defeated Pinochet,
the pleboscite.
There's a movie called "NO."
Some of you may have heard it.
I was a member of that
executive committee.
And then I had a lot of posts
as ambassador to the US,
in Washington, to Brazil,
and ambassador to the UN,
aside from being minister.
My country was minister
Secretary General
of the government.
I was deputy foreign minister.
So I had a lot of
experience but never
had I been put before
such a challenge.
And, sure enough, as soon
as we arrived in Pakistan
to begin our work-- we went
to a lot of preparation,
of course-- a lot of
surprises began to occur.
I had some warnings.
There was a Pakistani writer
that wrote a beautiful piece
in the "New York Times"
saying, basically,
that Pakistan is a land
of conspiracy theories.
And that is really complicated
because everybody's distrustful
and make up their own
stories about what
may happen to public
situations and incidents,
particularly regarding violence.
For example, he said when the
Sri Lanka cricket national team
was attacked in Lahore,
this writer, you know--
he says it in the
"New York Times"--
he went talking to people in
the streets of Lahore, asking,
so who do you think did it?
And people gather around him
and some said, criminals.
Other ones said, no,
terrorists, the Taliban.
And others said, the government.
And others said, no, the
intelligence agencies.
And somebody else said, India.
So conspiracy theories are very
easily encountered in Pakistan.
And so that wasn't very easy.
In addition to that,
Pakistan is a society
that has lived half of
it's independent life
under military rule.
So that democracy, evidently,
has been very challenged
throughout history.
And at the time, there was a
dictatorship, a dictatorship
of Pervez Musharraf,
General Musharraf.
And precisely Benazir Bhutto was
intent on returning to Pakistan
from her self-exile to
confront the dictator
and to try to recuperate
democracy for Pakistanis.
And that was the context
of her assassination.
She was returning to
Pakistan after being
out for quite a while, mainly
living in Dubai and London.
And her idea was to
rein in the military,
to make sure that the
intelligence services would
be under the oversight
of civilian rule,
and to make sure that the
country would begin going down
the road of development
and democracy.
And she was very keen on
repairing relations with India,
as well that has
always been the rival
in the mindset of Pakistan.
That was the context
of her return.
And the return had been
a return facilitated
by the United States and the UK.
The United States began
to see, even though they
backed Musharraf, very strongly
because Musharraf assured then
to the Bush administration--
the Bush-Cheney administration--
that the extremists would be
pursued by the government.
But the government had a lot
of dealings with the Taliban,
had a lot of dealings
with extremists.
For quite a while, in fact.
This wasn't new.
And they were playing
a double game.
Collaborating with the US,
particularly after 9/11,
capturing some al-Qaeda
types, and even some Talibans.
But on the other
hand, continuing
to have contacts with
them, and, in fact, to
have strong contacts with them.
Because in the mindset of
the Musharraf government,
they needed to have strategic
depth into Afghanistan.
And that dictated
the need to have
this relationship with
the Pakistani Taliban.
Being Pashtuns,
most of them, were
in common with most of the
Taliban in Afghanistan.
So that was the context.
And as Musharraf
began to be a problem,
the US began to see
that, increasingly, he
was not to be fully trusted.
They began to see that the
best formula for Pakistan
would be to have
Musharraf because he
was the man of the
Army that would ensure
the fight against terror, and
to have Benazir Bhutto that
would be the reinstatement
of democracy.
That was the best
of the two worlds.
And the idea was even, OK,
so why didn't Musharraf
remain as president so long
as he took off his uniform.
And Benazir Bhutto
as prime minister.
Benazir Bhutto had been
prime minister twice before.
She had never finished her term.
She had been dismissed
from office both times,
in '88 and then in '93
[INAUDIBLE] she served.
So that this was
a great challenge.
This was the context in which
the assassination takes place.
She goes back, in
October of 2007--
back, as I said, with the
idea that there's a deal.
She begins to have conversations
with Musharraf in Dubai
to have a deal.
So that she's
allowed to come back
without any trials
against her, particularly
for corruption cases.
Which was always a reason
why any prime minister
was dismissed in Pakistan.
And, on the other
hand, Musharraf
would take off his uniform.
And that would be then a deal.
But, of course, she was
contesting for elections.
And Musharraf was of the idea
that she should come back
after the elections.
In other words, in January of
2008 or around New Year's, New
Year's Eve or New Year's.
But Benazir Bhutto realizes she
had to campaign for her party,
the PPP, the Pakistani
People's Party.
So she decided to
come back in October.
And Musharraf felt that
the deal had been broken.
And he was irate
about her return.
When she returns on
the 18th of October.
And she's received by
practically half a million
people in Karachi, maybe more.
The estimates vary.
But huge crowds.
Huge crowds.
And she's in a truck
driving from the airport
to the mausoleum of the founder
of Pakistan, Ali Jinnah.
And as she goes very
slowly because there's
thousands upon thousands
of people in the road,
there's an explosion.
And an attack against her.
140 people die.
That was the way that
she was received.
On the one hand, with
the love of the people.
But on the other hand,
with a terrorist attack
that took the lives of
so many of her partisans.
So when we went, this was
what we wanted to unravel.
But she had actually been
killed not in Karachi.
She had escaped that.
And she had been killed in
a place in Rawalpindi, which
is relatively near Islamabad,
the capital of Pakistan.
In a park called Liaquat Bagh.
She had been assassinated,
immediately after a rally,
as she was departing the rally,
by a man who had shot at her
and, with a suicide vest,
had blown himself up,
killing 38 people and Benzir
Bhutto at the same time.
Interestingly, the place
where she was killed
was the same place, the park,
where the first prime minister
of Pakistan, the one who had
succeeded the founder, Ali
Jinnah, who had died
of natural causes.
He had been very sick.
And a very untimely
death because Pakistan
had become independent after
the partition with India.
And Ali Jinnah was the man to
unify the country and he died.
And his successor,
Liaquat Ali Khan,
was assassinated,
at the same park,
in the same place where, 56
years later, Benazir Bhutto
would be assassinated.
And he was assassinated at a
public rally, political rally,
by a gunman that shot him and
was captured by the crowd.
But nevertheless a
sub-inspector of the police
comes and shoots the
assailant six times.
So we never know who was
behind-- was he a lone wolf?
That attacked that
prime minister,
Ali Khan, Liaquat Ali Khan?
Were there other people behind?
Up to today, there
are controversies
about who was behind
that assassination.
So you can imagine--
this is the background
of the assassination
of Benazir Bhutto.
At this exact place.
Doing the book, I found
some unbelievable stories.
It so happens that when
prime minister Liaquat Ali
Khan is assassinated
in 1951, he's
taken to the military
hospital nearby.
And there's a doctor
by the name of Khan
that tries to revive him, fails.
When Benazir Bhutto
is attacked, she's
taken to a Rawalpindi hospital
nearby, a different hospital.
And the doctor in charge
is called Mossadegh Khan.
It so happens that Mossadegh
Khan is the son of the Dr. Khan
that had tried unsuccessfully
to revive prime minister Ali
Khan in 1951.
The ironies of history
are unbelievable.
Well, but going back
to the investigation,
I want to say just
a few more things
so that you have a chance
to ask me questions.
I found myself in
a world that was
very different from
what I'm familiar with.
I know Latin America very well.
And the clues are different
because the clues of politics
in Pakistan are mixed with
the provincial elements,
with the religious elements,
with the neighboring
conditioning, with the
influence of outside actors
like the United States
and the UK in the past.
Quite different.
And this, as I said,
conspiracy theory
and this constant leaking
of information, which I
was very upset about.
In fact, the day we were
going to go to Pakistan
the first time, I'm informed
that my communications
have been hacked.
So that we are very vulnerable.
So I tell the people at
the security at the UN.
And they said, well,
perhaps you shouldn't go.
And I said, no, I have to go.
And this was hours before
I had to take the plane.
And they said,
well, let's continue
talking while you stop in Dubai.
Because we were
stopped over before we
had to go to Islamabad.
And when I arrive
there, the communicator
said, well, we've been
thinking about it.
If you decide to go, you can go.
But stay within
the red zone, which
is the security zone
within Islamabad.
And I said, well, I
thank your suggestion.
But I can't because
the first thing I
have to do is to go
to Rawalpindi, to go
see the site of
the assassination.
That's symbolically very
important to the people
of Pakistan and important to me.
So what I decided was
that we would arrive there
and we would go to Rawalpindi.
But there were a lot
of press following us.
And possibly people that
might want to harm us.
And the first surprise
that I had was-- we
were in the security house.
Because we couldn't
stay at any hotel.
We couldn't stay at any
place of public access,
because of the dangers
that that would entail.
And the first surprise
is that the cook, who
spoke only Urdu, did not
speak a word of English,
had my detailed agenda.
And I said, how could the cook
have all this information?
And somebody gave
me an explanation
that was between
logical and absurd,
saying, well, he has to have
it, because he has to know when
you're going to be
here to prepare meals.
So I had to change everything.
And we decided to
play a ruse on anybody
that would want to harm
us and on the press that
followed as everywhere.
And we decided to say in
the program-- we actually
wrote in the program that
we would leave by helicopter
in the afternoon on the second
day that we had arrived.
Instead, we went the second
day at 5:00 AM, by cars.
And it was everything
very good until we
arrived to the Liaquat Bagh.
And the police put
barricades about two blocks
away so that we were in
an area absolutely free
of any vehicles,
any people, nothing.
But I saw, in the distance,
some people after the barricades
that they had put up there.
So the commissioner from
Ireland, the policeman,
told me, you know what
it is, you're looking at?
Those are journalists.
And, sure enough, their were
cameramen and photographers
with tele-lenses who
knew that we were there.
So the leaking of
information was unbelievable.
We confronted many
of these challenges
in the investigation.
A government that was very
supportive at the beginning.
Because it was presided by
the widower of Benazir Bhutto,
by President
Zardari, began to be,
very warm and supportive as
they were, at the beginning,
but then, as we began to be very
serious in the investigation,
we didn't feel as welcome
as at the beginning.
And we had a lot of
difficulties, particularly
with several
individuals, including
the Minister of
the Interior, who
was appointment for
contact with us,
Rehman Malik, who
had been the security
person for Benazir Bhutto.
And, at the time of
the assassination,
he had been in the
backup bulletproof car.
A backup car that obviously
had to be very near
the main car in which
Benazir Bhutto rode.
And it so happened
that it disappeared
at the moment of the attack.
We never saw it in
any of the videos.
any of the pictures.
And as I interrogated the
Minister of the Interior,
constantly he avoided
answering my questions.
And say, well, we'll
talk about it next time.
And that always was the case.
We found out, because
of the other occupants
in the backup car, that they
were between 150 and 250 yards
away.
They had departed before
the convoy had left.
And the rule in a convoy is
that everybody goes together.
And they had left
slightly before.
And, in fact, they
heard the bomb,
because that's what
they testified to us.
But, nevertheless,
they went away
to Zardari House, the house of
Benazir Bhutto in Islamabad.
That is about 25,
30 minutes away.
So the car that was there
to be the backup leaves.
They don't even ask what has
happened to Benazir Bhutto.
They just leave, probably
to save their skin.
It so happens that the
car of Benazir Bhutto that
was a very good car,
a bulletproof car.
Because of the explosion
had blown the tires.
So when they try to
get to the hospital,
they are riding on the
rims of the wheels.
And they don't make it.
They make it halfway.
She has to be transported
by a private car.
One of the militants-- one of
the activists of the party,
the PPP to make it there.
She has to be transferred.
Of course, she dies.
She dies.
Maybe she would have
been saved if she
had been taken immediately.
Difficult to say.
No autopsy was made, because
the police impeded it.
And the police, one hour
and a half after the attack,
washes the place of the attack
with hoses-- with fire hoses.
So that all the
evidence that should
have been collected in a site
protected was eliminated.
We were with Scotland
Yard in London.
And Scotland Yard told us that,
in an attack of that nature,
thousands and thousands
of pieces of evidence
would have been collected.
Only 23 pieces were collected.
So the assassination
was full of issues.
She was not
adequately protected.
Musharraf was very mad at her.
We found a letter that
the Musharraf government
had sent to provincial
authorities instructing
to provide VIP protection to
two former Prime ministers
but not to Benazir, not to her.
Specifically, she was excluded.
And the responsibility
to protect a former Prime
Minister was that of the
state, was that of Musharraf.
She was not
adequately protected.
But, in addition to that, there
was a cover up by the police.
And the police did not
act alone, in my view.
They had orders from above.
But, evidently, also she
was hated by the Taliban
because she was a woman
ruling an Islamist state.
Because she was a modern woman.
She had been raised in
the culture of the West.
She had been going to a
Catholic school in Pakistan.
Then she studied at
Harvard and then at Oxford.
She spoke better English
than Urdu, in fact.
She becomes involved in politics
once her father, Zulfikar Ali
Bhutto is killed,
is assassinated,
by the dictator in the 1980s--
late '70s and '80s, Zia-ul-Haq.
Who trumps up a case
to have him hanged.
Then she goes into politics.
So she was seen as a Western
woman, close to the West,
close to the United States.
In addition to that, somebody
who would fight for democracy,
that would come down
strongly on extremists.
So the Pakistani Taliban
clearly hated her.
So did al-Qaeda.
But there were many others
that wanted her out.
And she distrusted,
particularly,
the people around Musharraf.
She had sent a
letter to Musharraf
saying that she feared
the people around him,
specifically people linked
to the intelligence agencies,
to the ISI.
Hamid Gul was one of them,
a former ISI director.
Another one was
Ijaz Shah, who was
the head of another
intelligence bureau.
And a couple of
other individuals
who she felt very threatened by.
So that was the story
that I put up in the book.
I felt that I needed to get
it out beyond the report
that we presented.
Tell the stories behind it.
Last thing to close, when
we finished the report,
we presented it to the Secretary
General it had a lot of impact
in the media, in
Pakistan, internationally.
And I was with my wife on the
subway on Lexington and 59th.
And there was an individual
walking back and forth
on the platform, as if
waiting for the train.
And he looked at
me and I thought
it might have been
a Chilean because I
used to be an authority.
That was my country.
And sometimes when there are
tourists, Chilean tourists,
in town, I have been
recognized by some of them.
But this guy didn't
look like a tourist.
And he comes up, walks,
looks at me, and he asks me,
are you Ambassador
Munoz of Chile?
And I said, yes, I am.
Oh, he says, I'm Pakistani.
He says, you are the most
wanted person in Pakistan.
And I said, most wanted in a
positive or negative sense?
I say that very
nervously to him.
And he says, no, positively.
He said, I've see
you in television.
I've seen you in the press.
Your picture's all around.
I've seen the
interviews that you
gave when you
presented your report.
You did a great job.
I mean they all contributed very
strongly to clear up things.
But, he said, your
war will be lost.
Nothing will happen.
Because impunity is the
rule of thumb in Pakistan.
So the courts won't do anything.
And this will be forgotten.
Because that's the way-- he
began to be very passionate.
And I moved away and I
said, thank you very much.
And, my train is coming.
So that to close it
is to say that this
was a very important
investigation.
And it was important to me.
And it opened up the
court case in Pakistan.
An anti-terrorist
court opened it up.
And, in fact, today
the case is open.
And Musharraf has been indicted.
Even though he has
been released on
bail in the case
of Benazir Bhutto.
Final thing, for
me was important,
because I met her
in the early '90s,
when I was in Washington
serving my government.
And I went to US Congress
seminar on transition
to democracy.
She spoke about Pakistan.
I spoke about Chile.
And when we sat together, she
says to me, sort of whispering,
saying, you know, oh,
I'm so glad to know you
because I love Chile.
My father and I we
are so sorry, so sad,
when president Salvador
Allende was assassinated
in the coup d'etat in Chile.
Now we know that the
Americans were behind it.
That they supported
the right in Chile
and they pushed that
military coup because Allende
was a socialist.
That he wanted changes, like
my father wanted changes.
So I said, well,
thank you very much.
And I said, I felt very
close to your father.
Because when I was
a graduate student,
my best friend in graduate
school was a Pakistani
and we exchanged
notes about the--
at that time, the
detention-- and the overthrow
of Zulfikar Ali Bhutto by
the dictator, Zia-ul-Haq.
So I felt, as I said, close
to the reality of Pakistan
at that time.
And then later on, of
course, your father
was killed by the dictatorship.
So I want to thank
you and tell you that.
And so she gave me a
smile and shook my hand.
I never had anymore
conversation with her.
The irony would be that
20 some years later,
I would be investigating
her assassination.
So that's what is in the
book and many other things.
But thank you very much
and let me hear from you.
Questions and comments
that you may have.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: The story you tell--
I mean, listening to it.
It seems like a
story where there
is incompetence being
used to mask malice.
Like what you described with
what happened with the police
investigation, hosing
down the evidence.
When you were there,
conducting the investigation,
did you feel that a lot?
HERALDO MUNOZ: Yeah, I felt
that there was incompetence,
for sure.
But I think there was
more than competence.
I mean, I thought it was
acts of malice in fact.
That there was something
there that just didn't fit.
The decision to wash
the site, for example,
had not been taken
before in other cases.
Except, the military had done
that in some cases involving
attacks against high
military authorities.
But the police
knew that they had
to cordon off and
save the evidence.
And we heard that there
were phone calls that
were made from
intelligence agencies.
That might have
had an explanation.
The other side of it is that
the policeman may have thought
that an assassination of
such an important person
had to have higher-ups
involved and they themselves
decided to wash up, because they
better safeguard themselves.
That could have been
the other explanation.
But it wasn't something
that was casual,
that just simply happened.
That was a political
decision to do that.
Then the decision not
to perform the autopsy
on Benazir Bhutto
in the hospital.
That was a decision
of the police.
The police was
responsible for that,
according to the
law in Pakistan.
Nevertheless, the policeman,
the head of their local police,
impeded the doctor from
performing the autopsy.
So that was something else that,
to me, says that he got a phone
call from the deputy of ISI.
And they deny that to us
and then they recognized it.
After we showed that we have
evidence about that phone call.
Then they say, oh,
yes, we did call.
But we called just to know
whether she had fully--
that it was fully
clear that she had
died so that to relay that
information to our superiors.
So these things,
my feeling, just
don't happen by--
as something that
doesn't have a political
motivation behind.
And Musharraf he was irate
about her having come back
sort of undoing the deal
that they had tried to reach.
And not providing the
security was so important
that there was a
conversation that now we
have a lot of sources backing
up the conversation in which
Musharraf tells Benazir Bhutto.
When Benazir Bhutto
tells him, look,
the Americans are
going to call you
so that you provide security.
And Musharraf says
something like, look,
the Americans can
call all they want.
But your security depends on
the relationship between you
and I. Your security depends on
the status of our relationship.
That tells you-- tells
you a lot, I think.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I wondered if there were
any groups claiming credit
for doing this that you
thought was a reputable claim.
And if no one really
did try to claim credit
for it, why do
you think that is?
HERALDO MUNOZ: Yeah.
al-Qaeda claimed credit.
Through a spokesperson,
a high member,
they called a
newspaper, "Asia Times,"
to claim responsibility.
And, in addition to that, the
Musharraf government-- but this
was something of a boomerang.
Less than 24 hours
after the assassination,
a spokesperson from the
Ministry of the Interior
comes up and on
television and says,
this has been committed
by Baitullah Mehsud
head of the Pakistani
Taliban, of the TTP,
one of the major groups,
of the Pakistani Taliban.
And the cause of
death was Benazir
hitting her head on the lever
of the sun roof of the vehicle.
How do you-- the question that
experts and public opinion
posed was, how do you know who
did it and the cause of death
24 hours after it has happened?
There has been no
investigation, nothing.
And the Ministry of
the Interior claimed
that, because of
ISI information,
they had a recording of a
conversation between Baitullah
Mehsud and some other individual
where he congratulated
these people for having
performed a great deed,
by having-- they didn't
say, mentioning, you know,
by killing Benazir Bhutto.
They just, sort of,
indirectly suggested
that they were
being congratulated
because of this
terrorist operation.
When asked about this
Mr. Baitullah Mehsud, who
was, by the way, a
target of the US.
And finally, was taken out
in a drone attack in 2009,
by the way.
He react the same,
I didn't do it.
I don't attack women.
That's against Islamic
tribal traditions.
But, on the other hand,
there were a lot of evidence
that he felt that
Benazir Bhutto was
anathema to what he stood for.
Benazir wanted an inclusive
society, a democratic society.
She wanted to come
down on the extremists.
She wanted to control the
intelligence agencies.
So everything that
she stood for.
In addition to that, she
was considered a Shia
by these groups, Sunnis.
Because her mother was Iranian.
Benazir Bhutto's
mother was a Shia.
So that was an element too.
So it is very
difficult to conceive
that Baitullah Mehsud wasn't
involved, despite the denial.
So that, in the
end, I try to think
a lot about the big question.
So who did it?
The only thing that
comes out to me
is a Spanish play, a
17th century Spanish play
called "Fuenteovejuna."
Fuenteovejuna is a village.
And the story goes
that this village
was ruled by an
individual that was
quite heated by the population.
And one day this
individual is assassinated.
And a judge arrives
in town to investigate
who's the murderer, who
assassinated this man.
And he begins to
interrogate every villager
of Fuenteovejuna.
And every villager says,
Fuenteovejuna did it.
The village did it.
And they go one by one.
And the judge doesn't find
anybody except everybody
saying the village did it.
Fuenteovejuna did it.
He even tortures some
individuals and they all say,
Fuenteovejuna did it.
And as a sort of
parallel, as a metaphor,
I thought, well, Benazir
Bhutto, in a sense,
was killed by Fuenteovejuna,
was killed by the village.
Because al-Qaeda
wanted her dead.
The Pakistani Taliban executed
it through an individual.
The actual murder,
the suicide murderer,
was a
15-and-a-half-year-old kid.
Less than 16 years old.
We were with Scotland
Yard and they
were able to determine
the exact age.
A 16-year-old doesn't
do it on his own.
So, in fact, we saw
a piece of a hand
because that was
one of the remains.
And there were
these drawings that
were tradition in Pakistan
are the drawings that you
have for a wedding.
Because of the idea that he
was going to a better place.
And he was going to have the big
weddings with many, many girls
that wait for him.
So he was manipulated
into doing this.
Who was behind?
But clearly, the Pakistani
Taliban were involved.
The police, local
police, was involved
because they tried a cover up.
The people around Benazir, the
security people, failed her.
Because they didn't
protector adequately.
And I have a lot
of anecdotes aside
from the fact that the
backup vehicle wasn't
there when it should have been.
The United States and the
UK promoted her return
but they wouldn't take any
responsibility for her safety.
In fact, they said at
the beginning, well,
we look at hiring Blackwater
or some other outfit.
And then Musharraf
did not allow anybody
from abroad, any foreigner
to perform police duties.
In addition to
that, my perception
was that Musharraf
was a facilitator.
Because he did not provide the
security that she deserved.
They knew that she
had been attacked.
They passed on to
her information
about cells that were
bent on attacking her.
But they passed on information
to wash their hands
about the duty to protect her.
So they were part of it, too.
And, in the end, my perception
was that most Pakistani actors
would rather turn
the page than to know
exactly what had
happened to her.
So there were many-- the village
assassinated her, in a sense.
There were too many people
that wanted her dead.
AUDIENCE: This is a bit
of a naive question,
I think, but, I'm
from California
and I've lived in the
United States my whole life.
And I just wonder--
let's see, I'm
trying to think how
to pose the question.
How it feels like living in
a place where there's not
law and order in the sense
that I think of it here,
like under Pinochet,
or under Musharraf.
I mean, is daily life for
people substantially different?
I mean, you've lived
here for some time,
so you have a good
sense of that.
HERALDO MUNOZ: Well,
I would say that Chile
under the dictatorship was
very difficult to live under.
And, in the end, you adjust.
And if you decide to
confront the dictatorship,
becomes dangerous.
And in the case of Pakistan,
it's a little bit different.
The society has become
more radicalized.
It was always a very
sophisticated society.
It has a strong middle class.
A very learned elite.
And that began to change with
Zia-ul-Haq, in the late 1970s
and '80s.
When this radicalization,
Islamist radicalization began.
You know, the army
used to have dinners
that they ended
drinking port wine.
All of that was changed when
the strict Islamic tradition
was instituted.
And Sharia law and all.
So that then the society
became different.
Of course, people
continued drinking.
And there was an
article yesterday
in "Dawn," the
major newspaper, how
drinking alcohol was
driven underground.
But it's still all
over the place.
And it became a bit
more difficult to live.
Because I remember
having gone to
Islamabad many years
ago, before this mission.
And Islamabad being
a very nice city.
Well, today it has all
kinds of-- every few blocks,
roadblocks, manned by individual
with guns and sand sacks
and all that.
And that has changed.
It has become a lot
more vulnerable.
But people go on
living their lives.
It's a sophisticated country,
sophisticated society.
In the case of Chile it
was more or less the same.
You go on living.
But it becomes
difficult at some times.
I mean, my life was
threatened a couple of times.
But then you decide
that it is worth it
because there's high objectives.
I was arrested in Chile.
My family did not like the
idea of me staying in Chile
but we lived and
lived through it.
But it's very different
when you come to US,
you see the differences.
During a dictatorship,
you don't talk in a bus.
Because don't talk policy
because somebody might hear you
that may denounce you.
You are very defensive.
And that, I think,
is a frame of mind
that, obviously,
you don't have here.
And things are quite
different in that sense.
You distrust a lot of
people that you don't know.
You are with a strong circle
of friends and family.
And that happens under
repression, under dictatorship.
But today, Pakistan,
to go back to Pakistan,
I think is more hopeful
than anything else.
Because, for the
first time ever,
a government finished
a full period
without being kicked out,
without being a coup d'etat.
President Zardari
finished his term
and he handed over power to a
newly elected, democratically
elected, government of
Prime Minister Nawaz Sharif.
And that was a first
ever in Pakistan.
The problems today in Pakistan
are more development issues.
Electric power, issues of
true security, a country that
produced enough to feed
all of its populations
instead of import a lot.
Issue of energy is fundamental.
There are other issues that,
today, are more important.
And the radical groups have
always been a minority.
They never won an election.
They never won a
national election.
So, in the end,
there's more of a taste
for an inclusive
society more and more.
If not secular, at least
inclusive and tolerant rather
than the strict,
extremist views that tend
to be a minority in Pakistan.
And in the case of
Chile, as I said,
it's a different situation.
But we defeated a dictator.
And today we've had in a
20 some years of democracy.
And a woman elected
president of Chile.
The first woman elected prime
minister of an Islamist state
was Benazir Bhutto.
And very possibly next weekend,
and I'm going to Chile to vote,
Michelle Bachelet
will be re-elected
president of Chile,
I hope, at least.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
What's the evidence
against Musharraf?
And do you think he is the right
person to stand trial for this?
HERALDO MUNOZ: Well
it's not for me to say.
It is for the Pakistani
courts to decide.
And they opened up a case.
An anti-terrorist
court in Rawalpindi
opened up a case on
the assassination
of Benazir Bhutto.
And decided to indict Musharraf.
They took a lot of the
elements of our report,
but they have
their own evidence.
They have their
own means of proof.
And that's why I've
always said, it's
not up to anybody
outside Pakistan
to determine who did this.
It's up to the
Pakistani justice system
to exonerate or to
declare culpability.
And that's what they're
doing right now.
So far different courts
have indicted and condemned
the chief of police
of Rawalpindi
and the deputy chief of police.
Both removed from their posts.
And others have been removed
from their responsibilities
and put into an exit list.
In other words, they cannot
leave the country until
their situation in
court is cleared up.
So a lot has happened and
in the case of Musharraf,
the evidence has been
gathered by this court.
By the way, the state
prosecutor in the case
of Benazir Bhutto in
this Rawalpindi court
was assassinated.
About six months ago or so.
Her body was riddled
with bullets.
Many people say because of
the Benazir Bhutto case.
Others say that it
could have been because
of other cases
involving militants.
We have no evidence
that we could present
except the political one,
the political responsibility.
It was his responsibility
to protect her.
He didn't.
He didn't do it adequately.
And there's all
these other elements.
And, in the end, she sent a
letter to Wolf Blitzer of CNN.
And said, shortly before
the assassination,
saying, if I'm assassinated
is because of minions--
and used the word minions--
around Musharraf who did it.
But evidently, all of that
has to be proved in court.
And that's what is
happening right now.
MALE SPEAKER: I think that's all
the time we have for questions.
Thank you very much for
coming to Google and speaking.
HERALDO MUNOZ: Thanks to
you for the invitation.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]